Hey salut comment allez-vous ?
Moi ça va extrêmement bien !
Et ça va aller moins bien dans quelques minutes.
Pourquoi ? Parce que on va jouer à un jeu d'horreur.
Il s'appelle Home Sweet Home.
Home ça veut dire maison, sweet ça veut dire mignon
sauf que la maison va pas être mignonne là, vu ce que y'a dedans...
C'est un jeu taïwanais.
Voilà c'est la seule info que j'ai sur ce jeu allez c'est parti.
Alors ce qui est chiant avec ce jeu c'est qu'il est extrêmement beau parce que c'est Unreal Engine,
et quand c'est extrêmement beau on fait extrêmement caca culotte.
C'est quoi ce bruit ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ce bruit ?
C'est de l'autre côté ?
Ah j'ai trop peur d'ouvrir la porte mec ! Faut y aller !
Ok, on est bien.
C'est quoi ce bruit ? Ah, c'est la radio.
Ta gueule.
Hé y'a eu un bruit en vrai...
Putain, eh j- à chaque fois je fais ce coup là mais c'est vrai.
Là y'a vraiment eu un bruit en vrai...
Et on vient d'où? On vient de là ?
J'peux plus ouvrir ?
C'est verrouillé.
Ça me met en confiance...
Y'a pas une clef ? Ah bah voilà regarde.
Oui !
Du coup j'ai une clef, je peux l'utiliser...
Dans la porte je suppose ?
"E: Use Key"
E : Utiliser la clef
Putain c'est bien fait hein ! On est bien là !
Aw putain, c'est là qu'va y avoir- c'est sur...
C'est obligé.
Ouais, ouais. Très "creepy" mec, très très très "creepy"...
Ça va pas venir derrière ?
Hé, j'me demande d'où ça va venir en premier en fait...
Ah la pute !
C'est horrible !
Okay vas-y, j'm'en bat les couilles j'descend.
Tu m'entends ?!
Tu m'entends renifler du nez au moins ?
What the fuck ? What the fuck ?
Allez on y vas on y vas on y vas !
Attend ! Nan, là c'est pas possibl-
Nan normalement, t'as pas eu le temps hein...
Ton talon dépassait encore au moment où on est arrivé.
Putain je suis outré et franchement
les monstres comme ça, ils m'énervent.
Alors on avance, hein, on arrête de-
Oh!
What the fuck mec ?
Y'a du putain de sang...
Et une trainée par terre ?!
Faut qu'j'suive la trainée, c'est ça ?
Oh putain...
Mec c'est trop badant ce jeu !
Mais non !
Nan !
Hé, y'a un problème de cou avec cette dame !
AAAH !
Elle m'a niqué les oreilles la pute !
Casse-toi casse-toi casse-toi !
MERDE !
Oh, y'a une porte qui est apparu !
J'vais dedans !
J'referme !
Un casier un casier un casier !
Oh putain on peut se mettre dedans !
Va t'en, va t'en-Fuis !
Allez sors d'ici...
Sors d'ici...
Voilà...
Putain elle rôde hein-
Ah non elle est repartie dans son sang !
Très bien !
J'peux passer aussi dans le portail ou pas ?
En mode Docteur Strange d'un coup, elle m'apprend à faire des portails.
Remarque faire des portails de sang, j'avoue ça ne m'intéresse pas tellement...
Ça c'est-
Ouaip !
On va faire le tour pas de soucis !
Ah, il faut trouver- il faut trouver un truc pour euh... Le couper.
Du coup, on va d'voir sauter là-dedans ?
Une corde, ouiiii...
Tu paries ça va être une tête.
Une tête coupé.
Ah non c'est bon.
C'est une pince. Putain c'est rare qu'on trouve c'quon veut !
Euh...
Euuuuh
Wait wait wait !
Faut qu'je coupe vite elle va arriVER ! ! !
COUPE PUTAIN DE TA RACE Y'A UN PORTAIL ELLE VA ARRIVER !
Ah non, c'est bon, elle a juste fait un portail pour me faire peur...
J'ai paniqué pour rien mon gars.
Allez, on a coupé t'façon on peut passer...
Oh putaiiin...
Na mais les mecs quand ils font le mixage audio du jeu ils disent :
"Allez tout ce qui fait peur,
Tu mets à +20 décibels !"
COMME C'EST MOI QUAND JE PARLAIS VOUS ENTENDIEZ ÇA !
Affreux quoi, c'est quoi qu'est hanté maintenant...
C'est un goblet quoi...
Ils savent plus quoi inventer c'est un truc de ouf !
Aaaaah, le talon !
Toujours le talon !
On va l'appeler Achille, le talon d'Achille.
Alors tout va être fermer sauf bien sûr,
LA porte
où elle est allé,
et moi je parle pourquoi
pour me rassurer ! Parce que je ne suis qu'un con !
Je vais vraiment me barrer, et pas aller dedans.
J'en ai rien à foutre.
Aah ! Voilà !
Une chambre, avec une porte derrière...
Oh mais non, elle m'enferme dedans.
T'es sérieuse tu m'enfermes dans les chiottes pour de vrai là ?
Ah le TALON !
On l'a vu ! Coucou !
Un jour elle va vraiment être là !
Elle va vraiment être là et qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Bah je vais perdre un million d'abonnés pourquoi ?
Un million de crise cardiaque !
Euuuuuuuh
Okay on peut péter-faut un- trouver un-
Ça boque la route faut trouver une sorte de marteau.
Ici y'a quoi ? Des clous ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait ?
Ah bah ! Un pied de biche ! C'est très bien ça !
Elle vomit des clous ?
What the fuck ?!?
Ça me plait énormément, bon allez on se casse.
On y va...
Allez allez !
Ça dégage les planches !
Voilà comme ça j'peux passer
C'est-Là, c'est la fin d'la démo c'est ça ?
Hein ?
Oh putaaain...
Le pire couloir.
J'pense pas que- ouiiii- que c'est possible de tomber sur des couloirs pires que ceux de Outlast
J'vois rien ! ! !
Ah c'est bon putain...
Eh mec si elle nous cours dessus en rampant...
T'sais, ils adorent faire ça dans les jeux-euh... Asiatique d'horreur...
C'est des rats c'est des rats...
Madame il faut arrêter...
Il faut arrêter la cocaine.
Elle pleure- pourquoi tu pleures ?
Tu m'étonnes qu'elle pleure, ça doit faire mal de vomir des clous mon gars.
Déjà quand tu vomis des pâtes chez toi à 4h du mat' après une soirée t'es-t'as mal !
Mon gars, des clous !
AAH !
Oh la putaiiiin...
Elle est là ?
Elle est là, je l'entend marcher.
Elle a mit des talons la CONNE !
Oh putaiiiin...
Elle est passé devant nous elle est allée à gauche.
On est bon. On est LIBRE !
Oh, eh mec...
What the fuck mon gars ?!?
Mais pourquoi ça pisse le sang partout ?
Allez, ça dégage.
Un cir-
Un circuit- Ah putain il faut trouver un fusible, c'est ça ?
Faut trouver un fusible pour avoir accès à l’ascenseur c'est ça ?
J'ai cru-
ELLE ARRIVE !
ELLE ARRIVE ! !
ELLE ARRIVE ! ! !
J'passe juste devant elle m'regarde !
Ah c'est parfait.
Elle sort de son portail, j'passe devant, j'lui ai fait un tchek !
Ah, elle a ouvert la porte du coup.
C'est très bien ça
Du coup, j'ai accès à cette salle.
Oh, c'est quoi ça ?
Ah, c'est pour se pencher, okay.
C'est quand t'es caché.
OH LA PUTE !
Oh la grosse pute...
Steak haché (s't'es caché) !
Bah elle m'a pas suivie...
Elle m'a pas suivie.
Elle est où ? J'la voit pas. Où es-tu ?
Elle est là hein, elle veut pas bouger.
Sa vie c'est ça !
Ah, okay faut qu'j'la contourne.
Oh la pute.
Oh la pute...
Oh la PUTE- !
AAAAAAAH ! ! !
MAIS ELLE EST SUPER VIOLENTE !?!
M-Mais elle s'est pris pour d'euuuh...
Pff ! Elle a pas perdu de temps !
Waah, elle va voir d'quoi- de quel sang on se mêle, hein...
Ça veut rien dire.
Elle nous a pas vu, elle nous a pas vu,
C'est chaud mec !
C'est bon on peut y aller, on peut y aller...
Faut aller dans les chiottes ?!
Ou c'est un piège ?
C'est un guet-apens ?
Pourquoi y'a des journaux, mais j'm'en bats les couilles !
"Shocking news"...
M'en bat les couilles, veut juste sortir d'ce, j'm'en fout, j'm'en...
C'est bon...
J'le lirais quand je serais chez moi.
Elle rôde mec hein... Elle rôde hein.
Nan pour de vrai hein. C't'un rôdeur hein.
Elle est où ?!
Elle-elle est derrière le mur à droite j'dirais hein!
Ah putain, j'suis pas serein...
J'suis pas serein...
AAaaahhh ! ! !
Voilà.
Ch'uis pas là.
Ch'uis pas là !
Nan, m'elle CAMPE devant les CHIOTTES !
Mais t'as pas autre chose à faire que de camper d'vant les chiottes meuf ?!?
Putain ! J'peux courir ?
Ah bah j'crois- mais- en fait j'crois qu'faut courir hein.
Allez vas-y, nique sa mère.
Nique la république.
Nique la démocratie.
Ta race. J'm'en bat les couilles.
AAAAH !
Très mauvais choix de jeux ça quand t'as la gorge sensible, hein !
Okay c'est bon. Regardez, on est en train de l'esquiver...
Elle est trop con.
Okay on est passé.
Oh putain...
Donc là logiquement, va y avoir le fusible,
c'est ça hein?
C'est maintenant, c'est maintenant,
C'est maintenant, c'est maintenant, c'est maintenant, c'est maintenant-
J'peux m'lever ou ça f'ra trop de bruit
non ça va j'peux m'lever-
Oh putain !
Putain !
Oh la chatte qu'on a ! Oh la chatte qu'on a !
Okay j'y vais.
Ta race.
J'm'en bats les reins.
M'en bats les reins,
m'en bats les reins...
Elle va m'avoir, elle va m'avoir c'est sûr elle m'a-
MAIS NAN !
NOOOOON ! ! !
Mais c'est dure-euuuh ! ! !
Nan mais nan...
Ah c'est bon, y'a un checkpoint.
Bon.
Elle est où là...
Tu l'as vois à travers ce trou ?
Ah okay elle est là, regardez elle est là j'la vois elle s'approche !
Elle a mit ses petites Crocs, et elle va. Nous. Croquer.
Nan elle s'arrête.
Okay c'est l'moment.
Là normalement, ch'uis à l'abris ici.
C'est bon elle est la-bas on peut passer
On dégage d'ici mon pote
Voila on va vivre un coup
C'est parti il met son petit fusible
Ça passe au vert on l'appelle
La 'faut vite se casser 'faut très vite se casse
Allez allez allez on est bon
Ok on est passé et là on appuie sur...
Mais non..
Ah oui il a été foqué là
OOOH
Vite ouvre-toi
dépêche-toi fast fast (x?)
HOP p'tit tchek comme tout à l'heure
Allez vite 'faut courir
C'est parti oh putain y'a des trucs qui bougent
Elle se vénère
Mais attends il cours très lentement le mec
Ah le son s'est ralenti ok j'ai compris c'est le son de demain au quart finalement
Ouais LEAVE ME ALONE
Oh oui oui
Allez on s'enfuie
*Jumpscare intense*
Merci d'avoir jouer à la démo
Le jeu sortira en entier le deuxième trimeste 2017
Putain !
Eh bah voilà les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur ce petit jeu d'horreur
Putain en ce moment on fait des jeux d'horreur c'est des tueries
C'est la même mécanique que Outlast ce que le jeu a l'air des fois les espèces du sons simulator
Y'a un putain de montre tu sais qu'il peut te choper comme ça et te planter comme ça
Il est pas là pour jouer à roche-papier-ciseau si tu vois ce que j'veux dire
Et tu dois l'esquiver pour atteindre la sortie
Mais tu sais très bien que la sortie va se boucher
Comme le périphérique extérieur de Paris à 18h
C'est un putain de jeu n’hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu
On se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
Mais peut-être un p'tit peu de faim parce que la voie ça *effet sonore* beugue
Effet sonore de qualité
Allez à tous pour une prochaine vidéo portez-vous bien !
Je vais me refaire un thé ! Ah Yann *rire*
Tchao tout le monde . Peace !!